you know leaving this movie I actually
felt better about life because I knew
that I would never have to watch it
again
the apparition is a new horror movie
starring the girl from Twilight Ashley
Greene some dude who I I don't even I'm
not even gonna bother looking his name
up and tom felton or Malfoy from Harry
Potter that's right this movie stars
someone from Twilight and Harry Potter
young preteen heads exploding everywhere
when I saw the trailers for this movie I
was thinking hmm yeah that looks pretty
bad that really looks not so good then I
saw this when I saw that it had a 0% and
when I'm filming this review it still
has one it may have changed by now but I
got excited I wanted to go to this movie
and I just wanted to tear it apart
I just wanted to rip it to shreds and be
that one guy that guy that's like you
know what this movie mmm
but actually yeah it's horrible I hate
this movie the apparition is amazing to
me I was shocked by this movie it
bothered me on a psychological plane in
my brain and not because of how scary or
disturbing it was but because it
actually exists and it makes me scared
for mankind what's even scarier is that
when it ends it says written and
directed by the same guy some guy wrote
and directed this movie when you write
and direct a movie then it's close to
your heart in some way more than likely
somebody got in there and ripped this
movie apart I don't know some studio
executive or something the movies about
this couple Ashley green in this guy
they get this house that is like way
beyond their price range
she works at a dog kennel and he's like
some techie at some office it is covered
in literally one scene for about 30
seconds this guy has a job somewhere
that's all you need to know and
something is in there some some thing is
in the house and it's bothering them and
making sounds at night and it's
essentially paranormal activity without
the found footage gimmick honestly
that's what this movie is but the
basically the entire movie is just
people wandering through corridors
hearing loud noises intently turning
around oh my god what's there nothing's
there okay but it's cool because she's
wearing lingerie just got out of the
shower so you don't mind watching and
that's honestly the biggest draw for
this movie for me is the fact that the
lead actress is attractive that's
horrible I'm not kidding though there
honestly there is nothing scary in this
movie except loud noises and weird
sound effects that's it the studio
behind this movie the filmmakers who put
it together the writers whatever have no
idea what scares people
this is one of the most unscary movies
I've seen all year that's trying so hard
to be scary it honestly is just people
slowly walking through hallways hearing
loud sounds and turning around and
nothing is there that's it
that's this movie if you want to go see
this poem and pay for that be my guest
you'll hate your life and you'll want to
die afterwards sitting here right now I
can make this movie watch that is the
level of scares that you will obtain
from this movie are you gonna watch it
you shouldn't now if you can guess
already I'm not gonna recommend a thing
about this movie there's nothing
recommendable in this movie at all I try
very hard never to spoil anything in my
reviews unless I give you a very clear
warning beforehand so look if you have
any interest in seeing this movie
you shouldn't I'm about to spoil
something for you from this movie you
should listen anyway because it doesn't
matter just don't see this movie don't
give them any money don't care about
this movie you've been warned spoiler
warning check out the poster for this
movie yeah that looks pretty creepy
right check out this last shot in the
trailer that's pretty scary isn't it
yeah that's the last shot in the movie
that's the ending of the film the poster
before walking into the theater that you
turn and see and the trailer that you
probably saw before seeing this movie
spoils the entire ending of the movie
yep how can you be a studio executive or
a trailer editor or a director or
whoever is responsible for the marketing
campaign that literally spoils this
entire movie how can you care that less
about your viewing audience you really
honestly do not care at all about the
fact that they just spent like an hour
and a half mercifully this movie is very
short out of their day to sit in the
theater
hey view money you don't care if the
movies been ruined for them you do not
care at all you just want their money
that is what these people are doing to
you if you go to this movie I'm serious
this movie is not only horrible it
exists purely to take money out of your
hard-earned
bank account and give it into their bank
accounts where they have lots and lots
of money that you don't have so please
don't see this movie because they do not
care about you that's the honest truth
ok this isn't just a horrible movie this
is a giant marketing scheme to take your
money when they don't deserve it also
one more thing about that poster look at
that tagline yeah that has nothing to do
with the movie there is nothing about
believing in this thing and now you die
no it's just there and it's trying to
kill you it has nothing to do with
whether it doesn't care if you believe
in it or not it's there and it's gonna
kill you entire marketing of this film
is a complete ploy and why don't see it
there's nothing scary about it the
acting is awful the writing is awful the
direction like they show found footage
of things that people find and of course
it looks like this like you do realize
that we all have HD cameras nowadays and
they don't fail at all times and there
isn't lines through it anymore like some
old 1975 television that's not how it
works anymore people how dumb do you
think we are
ah what a horrible movie it wasn't just
the fact that it was so bad that
surprised me it was the whole marketing
thing behind it and I realized it
honestly it's just people in suits in
some room going this movie sucks how are
we gonna get the most money out of
people ok we'll make some giant marking
things online we'll get them in there
and then okay whatever by the time they
left the theater they already paid for
it so it doesn't really matter does it
let's make money it's yeah the
apparition is a horrible movie it's more
the worst I've seen all year I don't
know if it's as bad as piranha 3dd but
my goodness from a marketing perspective
and from a caring about your audience
perspective it's one of the most
atrocious experiences I've had the
theatres in a while it's an F for sure
do not see the apparition please just
stay away go see premium rush shame on
you Hollywood people shame on you and as
always guys if you like this review then
you can click right here and get stuck
Minh dies